oh it's bunnies oh cool
hi are bunnies like this big usually
yeah this one has red eyes it's crazy
that is not how you pick up a bunny hi
I'm Tony and this is my bun wife Braxton
as you can tell from our names we're big
music lovers our favorite activities are
going on walks at the beach and cuddling
while watching TV whoa I was in my mom's
life for five years until one day she
realized I needed to go from Bachelor to
husband and Braxton and I have been
Inseparable ever since we hope our mom
will find love as true as ours
okay all right
I'm sorry
do you want a banana
Tony where'd you go
I'm gonna go around
no come back Tony and Braxton are very
independent I feel like whoever is the
owner is probably really independent